I'm here with no GameSpot stock members
nope we have mine usurped supplanted
thrown out it's a coup that's a way
better one Matthew Mercer for critical
role how you doing good good about
yourself I'm doing fantastic Maurice are
a high critical role that's oh yeah how
are you doing double dip in there I know
we're gonna use all in Quad dipping in a
second now we roll deep we came in the
old quad dip yeah sex aids number one
Episode one learned it here folks it's
like a Sugar Ray lyric quad dip bring
him back in there the kids love oh yeah
that's a reference thank you so much for
coming in we had a lot of fun around
this table about an hour ago playing
Dungeons & Dragons yeah how'd you like
it yeah I loved it I D&E is one of that
we were talking just before we went live
about how you had that friend who had
Nintendo you sort of kept close to yeah
gene D is one of those things if you
have a good like Dungeon Master it's
such a great like things you can keep
them around yeah exactly like I I knew
some people in London when I lived there
for water we got out and we kind of
dipped in a little bit since I moved
here did a little bit with Giant Bomb
our sister website nice but a but
haven't really like gotten into a
property in a couple years until today
again there you go thank you very much
yeah welcome for your fantastic you say
you you also have like the patron saint
of DMZ I don't why it's the sounds of
fish beasts being torn apart I have a
lot of it's been a lot of time alone
when I was a kid okay you gotta find
ways to pass the time like making the
sounds of fish heads being pulled apart
ya know it's great and I think more so
now it's a good survival technique for
younger adolescents right you know
social environment sounds much I was
younger a lot of kids like oh you're
good ninja master he can stay around no
you didn't really have that reaction
when I was a kid but uh yeah it's been
really cool to watch this whole tabletop
renaissance over past years and and so
many more people one getting back into
the game or two realizing what they were
missing when they were growing up and
trying it out for the first time in
finding out it's just a lot of fun yeah
for sure over the over the next hour
we're gonna talk a lot about video games
stuff but for the moment I do want to
talk about that with you guys cuz there
like I don't know the internet stuff
mechanism that allows the sort of
smaller pockets of our society to be
seen by way more people and in doing so
those it sort of like gathers all those
people around right yeah yeah people
find their niche yeah you know to find
their there crowd yeah that doesn't yeah
there doesn't seem to be like little
niches anymore there's no such thing
that's kinda it's like you know
previously geographical boundaries are
like closed Rabanne geez disappeared so
what's happening with you guys were
critical role obviously on geek and
sundry and that's you've got like a you
know their audience has been building as
well but like your show has exploded in
like a very short period of time it's
been on for about just over a year just
over a year yeah what was that something
you expect it to happen no we're still
kind of holding on for dear life we we
you know we've played the game privately
for two years beforehand and it wasn't
our initial idea to turn into a show we
were asked to take it online by Felicia
with geek and sundry we were kind of
remissed about it at first because when
you take something that's very personal
and you wanna enjoy it in closed space
and then put it in front of cameras in
the internet you're like standing in
front of a firing squad of commenters
being target yeah yeah and so we were
initially worried about that transition
and we figured you know we'd give it a
shot if people liked it able to do it
for a little bit of doesn't work out
we'll just go back to our game at home
and we found such an amazing community
that continued to grow and grow over
time that and it didn't have a huge
impact on how he played the game and
enjoyed it which is all right I guess
worried so we just kept doing it and
figuring out where it might land and
it's gotten so much bigger than we ever
expected yeah the other side to this
obviously is that your video game voice
actors as well by trade and when you
like put that in front of like you know
web producer like video producer it's
like [ __ ] gold
it's like deanzie which basically
involves like putting on accents and
being able to be walked in and you're
like yeah I'm gonna try and your natural
Irish accent I was like oh [ __ ] there
goes everything I mean we were both in
Ireland a couple of weeks ago yeah yeah
my one gets like well thicker when I go
home sure yeah
and then my girlfriend's like who the
[ __ ] you American eyes your accent when
you're at home I actually did an
American accent for her last night and
it freaked through the [ __ ] no stranger
danger
so Kinnear that's great speaker ever
like for me I was even like yeah honey
honey there's someone at the door
so I guess you brought it then onto geek
and sundry
yeah do you think that audience was
already looking for a D&D show or have
you like brought in a lot of people like
hey where's your audience coming from
who are they it started the geek and
sundry audience which were already it
was a phenomenal community of
like-minded geeks and gamers fans love
came in through like will we'd this
tabletop and so there big tabletop
enthusiasts audience to dive into right
there were the ones who kind of started
the inertia and then word of mouth man
can't knock it yeah it's good
tried-and-true old fashioned yeah it
works it started there and then began to
become just kind of this this weird
thing there aren't a lot of I mean there
were a lot of other real play game shows
that were on YouTube and such but it do
like live real play you know we're by no
means the first yeah and there were
great shows that I watched for years
beforehand that I thought were great
examples of D&D playing we just happened
to find an audience of people that were
at that time that wanted to see what it
was about and especially with twitch
which is a great format for other gamers
who are on there for illegal legends and
other game types do come across the
front page and that there is name be
likewise you're a bunch of people
standing here click on it be like I
don't know what's happening in an hour
later be like oh now I get the news and
Dragons I never knew it played like this
and people all of a sudden get this
renewed interest in something they never
really thought about or thought they
could understand yeah it's been really
cool to watch that grow so it's it's
this weird organic expansion that's my
favorite comment though is what the [ __ ]
am I watching what the [ __ ] is this
so you actually like converting people
like window shoppers who were just like
oh yeah we've gotten inundated with
tweets now weekly about people who have
started their own D&D games or have
decided to
pick up a dungeon master guide and start
dungeon mastering on their own so every
time we see one of those were like one
of us yes spread the joy yeah so what do
you think is like the special sauce of
critical role that has made it like
expand so quickly I don't know the only
way I can think of zero a lot of shows
that I really like and I think what I
like about the shows that I've watched
in the past like the real roleplay guys
it's me JP and and that the stuff that a
lot of those folks have done is it's a
group of friends playing a game if you
just take random people and put them
together to run a game sometimes it can
be it's fun but there's something to be
said about people who have built a
rapport over time and and maintain that
feel of just like chilling in the living
room unwatched playing a game and less
performing for the audience and since
we're all naturally kind of you know
bombastic indoor kids that you know talk
to ourselves a lot at the time it's an
easy transition for us and so I think
that is part of the appeal if anything
is the fact that we're all just been
close friends playing this game for a
long time so we have that rapport built
in and I don't know honestly that's the
best I can guess we're still trying to
figure out ourselves we're just glad
people to show up every week to watch it
it is hard to say because we're not
consumers right you do but maybe you can
probably even answer that question but
yeah than us it seems to be the sort of
you know each other's tails like it's
very comfortable yeah we've been doing
this now for three years with each other
so because you know we were playing the
game for about two years when we started
the stream right so we were very
comfortable I think it's also you know
something has to be said about the raw
storytelling element of it because when
the show first got pitched and
introduced the problem was that there
wasn't going to be visually engaging
yeah enough for today's audience it's
like people sitting down talking to each
other right three to four hours yeah you
know even the cast we were like there's
no way there's no way anyone is gonna
want to listen to this but it kind of
harkens back to the old sitting around a
campfire telling in Iliad kind of feel
to it and I think it shows how important
storytelling is especially in today's
medium when used
stripping away all the VFX right all the
flash that you see in modern
storytelling today in movies and whatnot
and it still shows that people still
need and want a solid story especially
if you've got a very good storyteller
which which you do have like there was
something when we did the stream right
here today like everything each of your
characters the way you were like
reacting the way you were like planning
attacks and not just the voices but just
like the body language of it all like in
my head when I think about what we just
did like I see the marsh I see exactly
what happened I see that the big
Maelstrom beast of bones and drugs it's
crazy
do you think it has something that is
well to do with with the ability of
people to consume like different types
of media like like during their day
because twitch is kind of this this
platform that you know like television
has always been you sit in front of a
new sort of engagement on a moment
moment basis sure is this seems like
something you could have on in the
background that you're sort of like
enjoying while you're engaging with your
day to day life I mean people were
tweeting today saying oh yeah my lunch
break yeah I'm just like spending a
couple of minutes or I've got it like in
my tab here yeah it's almost like like a
radio play in ways yeah exactly up lay
and so you know there's there's a lot of
really cool elements of watching so you
get to see the physical expressions and
reactions and looks of surprise and you
know the the maps and the minis and all
the fun stuff that's involved there the
physicality but you don't need that
either you like people to just listen to
it while they're doing chores or getting
their taxes done and I just reminded me
oh sorry just destroyed everyone but
that's also you know what's cool about
this format is you can't just listen to
the full audio and continue about your
day and have this adventure going on
behind you the whole time and I think
it's something different that the story
anyone who's watching it they're
discovering the story with the players
right yeah and so when you watch it live
there's definitely you have an adrenalin
that kicks in when you start seeing us
in moments of peril and I think you
wouldn't you know you don't necessarily
get that when it's a movie or then or a
game but I think when you're watching it
live and you realize that we are
and seeing it live with you it creates
almost a more interactive experience in
a weird way you feel more presents
probably yeah you feel like you're a
part of the story as it's been created
around you so that makes sense